oh good morning everybody I'm mark Ibis
from the end of university of technology
or ever more specifically from tech
united robot soccer team and I always
like to start my presentations off by
telling you about my dream it's the
dream of 2050 and this dream is a
specific one and I think everybody
should have thought about this before I
start the presentation so what I usually
do at the start of my presentation is F
ask everybody to close their eyes don't
do that because I imagine it's Sunday 9
o'clock don't close your eyes to skip
the movement but imagine you're in a
soccer stadium and imagine you're in a
soccer stadium in 2050 and you're going
to watch one of the greatest games in
human history because for the first time
you're going to watch a game of
autonomous robots playing versus the
human world champion so you're there in
the stadium you've got your seat and
then when the ceremony starts the
players are walking on the field and now
imagine what do those players look like
do they have flags do they have wheels
do they have two legs maybe three legs
do the Hoover across the field
do they have eyes to the other hat think
about this because we have already been
thinking about this for a long time
Robocop is a Federation of researchers
all across the globe which work in on
realizing this dream this dream of 2050
all the people in Robocop have thought
about this and are working towards that
moment in 2050 when the human world
champion is beaten by a pair or a team
of you autonomous robots a pair would
even be nicer in these but of course
this is towards 2050 this is an amazing
challenge it's big you need maybe lakhs
you need artificial intelligence vision
algorithms you need all kinds of game
statistics well luckily we are not all
with this enormous challenge we've or at
least the RoboCup has divided it in a
few parts so three of the league's which
are in robocop just to give you a
picture and these leaks all aim towards
a different part of this challenge so it
wouldn't be smart with all those
thousands of researchers to just start
reach they're researching towards that
or this autonomous team but we've
divided it so here on the left you see
the small-sized league small-sized
leaguers are ya hockey puck robots maybe
a bit larger they play almost eleven
verses eleven robots and it really focus
on strategy on the total right we see
the now robot probably you've all seen
them well if you know them and you like
them you should definitely come to
Robocop one day because these robots
play five versus five and it looks
really great
these robots playing soccer well you
know they are good at walking but they
walk a little bit stiff so it'll work
like this and then there is a ball and
then they lift their leg and then the
moment of tension is there because are
they going to kick the ball or will they
fall over before they do that a lot of
anthro morphism by the way because d
there are lots of people screaming at
these robots but in the middle there is
the middle-sized League and that's the
league we have robots on wheels and a
normal standard FIFA sized ball the main
thing here and I've also a point that
during the presentation a couple of
times these robots are autonomous
systems there is nobody controlling them
with a keyboard or a joystick once we
put these robots on the field they have
to do everything by themselves we cannot
do anything means you all know maybe
sometimes you check in a book in the
repository or something if that happens
with these soccer robots in the first
minute or screwed we cannot do anything
and for example all bosses will go wrong
can imagine what kind of tension and
Dynamics AX brings to a team the main
thing is middle sized league is
decentralized that means
every player can play soccer on its own
it has all the sensors and actuators
onboard and yeah this is actually it's
nice that we have this camera so this is
one of the soccer rules we have so this
robot can actually do everything himself
and that's the beauty on the other hand
we had a small size leak and that league
has a central sensing system so that
means these robots just gets commands
like go there go there from some central
computer so that means that if the
central computer falls away those robots
can't play and we can play these robots
our connection with Wi-Fi so it's a
multi agent system but I will get back
to that in a moment I was just talking
about these great team dynamics right so
I got one picture which explains how the
team feels during a match that's like
the whole spectrum on the Left we see
the people that well are not too
positive about what's happening then in
middle we have neutral surprise effect
and then on the right there are people
which are already a bit more positive
this is great this is the team tech
night at I know who we are building
these soccer robots a lot of different
emotions but at the end of a game
luckily last year there was only one
real emotion that was there because last
year in 2018 we became the world
champion in our league thank you very
much
a while ago I did a presentation I had
to wait wait two minutes for applause so
it's good that you are all awake that
means we became world champion in 2012
2014 2016 2018 we also see some kind of
pattern there but this year we're going
to break that pattern however adding
adding that we became second in 2008
2009 2010 and all the other year say in
between that means that we already
played 11 final matches in the world
championship in a row and that's that's
great but let's stop talking let's do a
video for watch a little bit of robot
soccer I guess that's the future anyway
so this was two weeks ago at the
Portuguese Open 2019 and we're playing
here versus the team of Portugal
[Music]
so it's a kind of a European
Championship the blue team is in this
case they attack United and we're a year
in the attack just take the token to
throw in trying to get around to
Portuguese offense which is really good
it's really difficult but with passing
trying shielding we managed to score at
least some goals
[Music]
always that keep her in the way to shake
[Music]
now they have to be robust to those
things trying to keep in the ball
rotating around
[Music]
[Applause]
of course this might happen at a
Portuguese team had some kind of failure
in a code causing the robots to stall
yeah we didn't take the opportunity
that's even worse I think so we could
have scored a goal there well just to
give you a bit of an idea this is I
already told you we're going to watch
robot soccer and hopefully we're going
to do that much more let me give you an
ID World Championship 2013 in ninth of a
year in the Netherlands in the South
grab on to need let's see what happened
in the final match there five seconds
before the game would end in normal time
we are Aztec United one goal behind we
score
[Applause]
these are thousands of people watching
robot soccer
this is not some clever video edit these
are really thousands of people watching
a soccer game with robots they have
already been looking at it for half an
hour it was extremely exciting of course
also because our home team was there for
this
unfortunately actually remember 2012
2014 it's not there
2013 we became second because in
overtime the Chinese team from Beijing
they managed to get our victory and this
is one of the most well yeah it's not
good
2013 losing in your hometown that's not
good but let me introduce you after some
robot soccer games so the real stars
these are the tech United Robo Cup team
limited editions Turtles
I always wonder what came first
abbreviation on the name but these are
the Turtles here we see one keeper we
have one of those on the field and for
field players and I brought one here as
well and let's see some things in action
because I want to tell you a little bit
about what these robots can do I already
mentioned that all sensors actuators and
computing has to be on this platform so
let me show you how this works so I also
got a video here but I can also show it
so maybe the camera can come a little
bit closer I can also climb a little bit
close to the camera because these robots
should be able to dribble with the ball
so will now show you the ball handling
system of the robots I've one colleague
over by the way over there
she's sick controlling the robot but
just standing keep the ball in your
claws and I will now show you that we
can actually take the ball with us
and actually go anywhere we want while
keeping the ball in our ball handling
system at currently I'm moving of course
the robot because if the would go some
if something would go wrong and it would
just drive in that direction we
shouldn't think about that but it's just
rolling the ball with the robot and
that's really important because it's one
of the rules
we've added and that's really nice say
because in Robocop we're aiming towards
2050 we're using already the loss of the
FIFA the FIFA rules of the match but
we've added some extra rules just to
make sure that these robots progress in
the right way because if you would play
the game of soccer without adding any
additional rules we've already seen that
you will get kind of like a tank robot
which just picks up the ball and then
move the ball to the other side of the
field like a tank throwing away all the
other opponents and then shooting
extremely hard but that's not what we
want so for example we added the rule
that if we use our robots to dribble the
ball the ball should roll almost
naturally so if I'm rolling the ball
then you also see that the ball always
rolls naturally I don't roll the ball
like this I'm stepping the ball around
and that's really important because the
ball always has to roll in our match if
that's not the case you can even get a
yellow card or a robot can get a yellow
card then comes the interesting part of
this morning because we can also shoot
it's of course necessary to win we're
close to the goal and will first show
you a flat shot just to make sure
everybody's awake so let's see I need to
aim it manually a little bit so for the
cameraman that we don't hit them so this
is not even full power yet we have to be
a bit careful your flat shot and be
careful people there on the first row so
they will see a flat shot and that's all
done by the robot autonomously ah this
is of course one of this stay new door
what does it work
happy kicking for the hoax yep it's of
course robotics yeah usually they do
everything autonomous but then at this
moment somebody is idyllic answer wait
no there is only one way to do this here
let's turn it off and on again also in
robotics that really works so I will
quickly progress it to the next slide
just to tell you something about the the
sensors of these robots we'll definitely
get back to the shooting by the way but
let's see yeah so this is one of the
additional sensors we have on the
platform so aside from activating we of
course also need to send so we have a
Kinect sensor on the front it's one of
those sensors which is usually with a
Xbox and in this case we don't use it to
stand in front of it and make a weird
motions but we use it to track the ball
as you can see in the video we try to
draw a red box around the ball that's
what we do with the Kinect but this
robot also needs to know autonomously
where it is on the field and it should
know that by using onboard sensors so
for example using GPS that's considered
as not on board using external signals
so we also have to do that have to find
some solution to do this on the robot so
that's actually why we use this omni
vision camera it's here on the top of
the robot it's the camera facing upwards
into a parabolic mirror and with that it
creates one of these warped images where
you can actually see a lot you can see
the field lines which we use to
determine where we are on the field we
see black obstacles those are the
opponents with a yellow ball and that's
all the input almost that we need for
determining what we should do and then
one of the things we could do is of
course kick let's see if it works are
you ready answer let's see second try
yeah is of course the demonstration
effect kay do a kick fo download shot
you'll always see that this goes wrong
your demonstration will have look after
the presentation quickly to see what's
happening and let's see um but I was
telling her I was telling about this
this vision system so we see black as
other robots we see yellow objects as a
ball we have green we have a green field
and white lines and that's approximately
all the colors there are and it's very
well defined so the environment in which
we work is really well defined and
that's great because we can just do
color segmentation everything which is
yellow is a ball everything which is
black is the robot works like that works
like a charm
so before like two years ago we really
didn't need any cool artificial neural
networks using vision that kind of stuff
we could just use color segmentation
everything which is yellow is a ball
works like a charm
but now we find that robots can also
play with t-shirts I don't have the one
from bobbin from pax looks around but we
have t-shirts so it can be orange they
can be all kinds of colors and that
means that this black part is still more
difficult to determine so we need to
look at how does the robot look and well
Anthony Horowitz
once that you cannot defeat your enemies
until you know who you are until you
know who they are that also really
applies to this so how do we know what
object is a robot and we have quite some
ways to find this because for example
it's quite violent shaped and you will
see all our opponents are also Pilon
shaped so our mission was to detect
robot players and identify to which team
they belong so finding robots should be
quite simple but then also finding to
which team they belong that you have to
do that with like the t-shirt guessing
the well the nation from the t-shirt
this is research done by one of my
colleagues
we are aiming to do is take pictures of
robots in this case we done a test with
our own robots we took a lot of pictures
from all different sides but this takes
time we took around 200 pictures you
know you need quite a lot of input data
so it took a lot of pictures but yeah we
imagined that at a World Championship we
were trying to do this and then yeah we
had to also take pictures of opponent
robots and you cannot ask the opponent
if we can just take four pictures that
would be okay but if you have to take a
lot of pictures that doesn't really work
so we were trying to find a way to do
this with less images say only four left
right front back and then we would
augment the data we would use a lot of
like these four images and turn four
into 32,000 images just by making sure
that we warp them in the correct way
because we are going to use this
algorithm for the only vision camera so
we need to make sure that we warp them
according the shape of this omni vision
sensor and then of course we would also
well apply color variations we would
rotate shift put a different background
there and all that to make sure that we
can recognize these robots on the field
as I already mentioned that's quite
difficult because robots come in very
different colors and different sizes so
this is say one of our normal robots you
sometimes get something like this this
actually doesn't work but this is one of
our opponents of course mechanical
engineers use a lot of duct tape so
that's why then we try to keep
everything together with that then you
also have robots which look a little bit
different this is a team using a
different top camera as we are using
this is the Portuguese team with their
magenta t-shirt this is a Portuguese
team with our scientist so this takes a
whole lot of time and a whole lot of
pictures so we're currently looking into
gathering all these images and still
trying to find this pile and shaped size
and it actually is already working quite
well so it is let's say we have an input
image which looks something like this so
this is a
one of those images from the Omni vision
camera these are three tech United
robots so the orange ones playing versus
one other robot during a game and this
is actually an in-game picture we took
and what we can then do is run an
inference a convolutional neural network
on it try to find the orange t-shirts
well that works quite okay we have all
three there is some outlier somewhere
over here no clue why but we use the
class activated bitmap so we can see
which features are activated and based
on those features we can see if it's
either the orange team or the blue team
in this case so in this case you see
also the blue recognition is of course
here that's really good one thing we did
notice with this data is we also have
the opportunity to put on some LEDs like
on the bottom of the robot Need for
Speed looks great kind of stuff but then
also box ourselves because you see that
the class activated bitmap also shows a
feature at the position of one of our
own robots so that means we have to put
it off these very cool lights but from
these activations we can actually see
using a blob detector which position a
certain class has whether it's blue team
orange team magenta team Zion team
whatever so this is currently ongoing
and I think that what sums the current
status is a little bit is that this is
working all fine but this is offline we
have pictures with autumn offline we in
France the CNN on a different computer
than on this robot so it's not working
in real-time and that makes it really
difficult so currently our future work
for this would be try to get it working
on for example and video Jetson board or
something similar or TPU which we can
just plug into our computer and try to
get this working in the loop not only
just on a computer on the side because
that's actually not allowed they should
be autonomous but trying to get this
word
in real time that's really difficult and
we're trying to see how we can include
knowledge we already have models to make
this faster so this is one of the things
we're working on so vision convolutional
neural networks trying to detect robots
and trying to take detect to which team
they belong let's see there's another
great saying know your opponent that you
will never lose know yourself and you
will always win Sun Tzu but the thing is
we thought we start with the first and
then we'll see how we end up with the
second thing that's always difficult and
know yourself so what we're trying to do
is opponent action prediction the thing
is we have a lot of data with these
robots collect data during a match they
collect all the things they see all the
things they know about themselves they
all collect that store that and after
the match we can unload it from the
robot and then have all that data we
already have it from 92 World
Championship matches and we thought
let's do something with that of course
we do something with it we use it to
track down bugs and see what went wrong
at each stage of the game but we're now
also want to use this game data to
predict the action of the opponent so in
research done by one of my colleagues
we're looking into is this possible is
this feasible so what we did because we
want to also get the ground truth what
was the opponent really going to do and
yeah we could classify of course what
the opponent is going to do but the best
thing is we can also try that on our own
team so without knowing what we are
going to do so which action the robot
decides to do we can just use all the
data we have like positions velocity we
also have that from the opponents we try
to train a network to predict what our
own robot is going to do and then we'll
use the ground truth data to oh well
give the the result of this this test so
to give you a little bit of test how
does this neural network
so we're going to have a stop here and
now the question to you would be what is
this robot going to do any IDs clues run
with it is one of the opportunities
indeed any other shoot on goal you can
also give a path but the main question
is so with this limited amount of
knowledge you have so with this 2
seconds of video is that enough for you
or for any neural network to predict
what this this or own robot is going to
do and the best thing I know what this
robot is going to do because I he
collected data during a match so we know
he's actually going to do something and
we can check whether the artificial
neural network actually predicts the
right thing but how to do this because
this game state this game state this two
seconds of video contains a lot of
information right contain spatial
information temporal information how do
you hand that over to an artificial
neural network and that's actually where
temporal occupancy grid Maps came into
place so I will have to explain this
probably this is a field a soccer field
or a small part of it actually and this
is one of our robots and our robot is
currently at position
2112 where they're 255 is and it drove
there on the route which is shown by the
blue blue blue path so this is the
temporal information this blue path
which is increasing in intensity and the
spatial information that's given by
which grid map cells are activated so
how does this look we can do this for
our own team all robots so we have here
on the top for example you see one which
has no diminishing tail so that's our
goal keeper you see some of our robots
are advancing downwards right the
intensity above is low and it gets
higher when it's done so somewhere here
is the opponent goal we also do that for
the opponents so we also have their
information where they have been and
where they are currently
we also devised such a deal and we can
do the same for a ball and then we
hypothesize that all the information you
just saw in the video is also in this
temporal occupancy grid map so again
from this picture you should be able to
say tell me what if I would query the
next section of this robot what that
robot is going to do yeah we'll see what
there is going on what we did is used to
convolutional neural networks there's a
lot of information I will quickly go
over it but this is one of the more
simpler proposed artificial neural
networks for such an application the
right one is something we add we made
some additions to that to make sure the
input data gets a bit more in the
network but not to bother you too much
with that what we did is a test
so can we actually do this it's alright
potus's will it work will this way of
temporal occupancy grid maps work and
what we did is we took four years of
data on world championships or at four
years back and we did an evaluation test
so we just looked at what does the
network predict and what do our robots
actually do and this actually showed
that if we use ten frames so that's
approximately half a second of data we
could actually predict our own action
with an accuracy of 77% which is quite
good because if we can use this
information this 77% there will be quite
nice if we would have that really during
a game there well the training accuracy
so it's testing it on the training set
not the validation set so that we could
even potentially use even more trained
games situation so training even more
yeah would still lead to a higher
training accuracy so that shows
promising results
but again this is also done offline so
we're currently also looking into if by
the way you see that in this case the
red line is a convolutional neural
network - so that's this network on the
right you'll probably think so if you
already look to some of the steps there
this is really hard to do this real time
and imagine while also playing soccer
that's that's the thing so this is doing
this real real time is really difficult
but we're working on it
the main question I always want to tell
everybody and that is why do you act
build robots I didn't get the question
today yet but usually I get this
question a lot why do you actually build
robots because it's of course fun but
can we just do something better like
saving the world or trying to solve the
world hunger problem or anything like
that why do we build soccer well soccer
is a great way to enthuse people to
progress research to robotics and
artificial intelligence you haven't been
for maybe some of you actually have been
to Robocop but if you go there there are
thousands of researchers which work if
they can if security of the venue
doesn't kick them out they work
continuously almost they want to win the
world championship in their league
thousands of top researchers in robotics
and artificial intelligence they're very
driven because they want to become world
champion also with our team we go with
ten people we make days from 8:00 in the
morning to 11:00 at night and the next
day we go on again all to win this title
but in the meantime we are progressing
artificial intelligence and robotics and
it's great because these technologies
can be used in autonomous driving
consumer robotics these kinds of things
we develop but we also within tech
united we want to make this more
concrete so we actually some years ago
built amigo which is the robot the era
second from right that's amigo and
that's our caretaking robot one of the
main things
think robotics in the future will
improve is that for example the lives of
our elderly here so making sure that
elderly can say at home longer that they
can for example get their medication
that maybe somebody can well bring them
to bed maybe even or guide them to the
toilet that would be great but as you
might know in Holland we don't we don't
have enough caretaking personnel so
usually we send them to some elderly
home and that's not the way we want this
and we think robotics can actually do
something here so that's first we built
amigo
then we built Sergio fully on the right
it's a robot which actually can bend
through his knees he doesn't have arms
yet we're currently working on that it's
of course important if you want to give
somebody someone medication you need
that and here on the second from the
left you see one of our robots which
here we are currently participating with
this is a robot by Toyota and it's
called the hero human it's a human
support robot and this robot is
currently also competing in the world
championship of caretaking robots how
does that look I hear I usually hear you
ask so this is say the final match in
the German Open this is still with amigo
and here we see amigo and certainly
there's no soccer field anymore there's
just a robot and a table and there are
some people walking around and this
robot now has to pick up soda can pick
it up and then bring it back to the
person who asked for it or put it on the
table the nice thing is these robots
they don't speak yet it's a it's an
ongoing project but you you can't
communicate with these also if you're on
the soccer field don't stand in between
the robot and its goal with amigo you
can amigo can handle people asking stuff
amigo can handle people that stand in
the way and just go nicely around it and
that's great because amigo is really the
first step towards this keeping elderly
at home
one of the things of course all elderly
use some kind of messaging service so
this is a final match an open challenge
where we use telegram to control the
robots so on the side on the right
you'll see the telegram messages so
check who's at the door and then amigo
will go and check there's barely so on
the door we have to take him to the
living room then sergio also comes in so
two robots walking around we have to
find someone called Yasha well
apparently she's in the bedroom we have
to take her to loss then they're
together we give them something to drink
[Music]
doing stuff with rivers is difficult but
that's this is really the next step and
the nice thing is Tech United is this
not only a soccer playing team but also
a team with caretaking robots and the
main thing is that there is a great
interface between those two teams these
teams are really working together very
well
methods we use in robot soccer are also
being applied in at home in this at home
league we call it and vice versa so we
can actually interchange all kinds of
theories and methods to make sure that
we really advanced robotics and
artificial intelligence well to in the
end also consumer robotics and also
autonomous driving but it would be
really cool if in 2040 for example that
would be well robot priced well feasibly
priced for elderly that they can
actually take one of those robots put
them in their homes and I will just say
hey you need to take medication hey I'll
guide you to the toilet if you want just
tell me what you want usually at the end
of this presentation I have one slide
which is if the whole presentation went
okay then I showed this slide that
autonomous robotics also can go wrong I
think you already know that it can go
wrong and we'll try another time but
just to let you because it's also a
funny video for this one maybe if
there's some extra sound will be nicer
so this is practicing a penalty some
years ago robot is ready to take the
penalty keep her in the goal
[Applause]
yeah yeah this is really bad yeah yeah
yeah this is autonomous soccer robot
well maybe a bit Buddha machine maybe
this was the time when we couldn't make
the video cuts exactly right so this is
of course this is Putin saying this was
at some marriage of our one of our team
members we wanted to show the people
that attended the wedding what kind of
great software he built so that's
actually what we did here I think they
only got a good impression about what
the thing is autonomous robotic soccer
is really cool and I hope to have told
you everything about that or at least
scratching the surface maybe a little
bit what I think is that robotic soccer
and hopefully it will go to mainstream
currently we see those things with
League of Legends for example and twitch
well why wouldn't these matches be
livestream to all across the group it
would be wonderful and that would really
be the next step towards 2050 when these
robots or maybe those robots you came up
with the 3 lakhs the 2 lakhs
maybe you bring robots those robots may
be able to look like the dream of one of
you but in 2050 beat the world champion
doesn't matter how they look like as
long as we can do that what we know for
sure is that by 2050 then we have
progressed artificial intelligence and
robotics so far that we probably already
have autonomous driving and we also have
great new consumer robotics but also
these robots at home for example which
we can help or LD stay home longer so
that was my presentation and possibly
there are some questions I guess so
I'm welcome to answer them
[Applause]